Crète étrangère il y a des siècles qui est toujours
debout aujourd'hui, donc c'est presque comme si nous
revenions aux bases en termes
de méthodologies de construction, mais en
les mettant à l'échelle, puis en les combinant
avec la technologie moderne et l'usine moderne
[Musique]
la réduction de carbone est massive  et je
pense que vous savez que le chanvre
est un peu comme un matériau de construction alternatif,
vous savez, ce sont des outils avec
lesquels nous pouvons
réduire ou avoir un impact sur le changement climatique.
à venir donc je
pense que heureusement, grâce à notre client,
nous avons en quelque sorte eu l'occasion d'
explorer des méthodologies de construction en lui
bien avant même que nous l'ayons local aujourd'hui
[Musique]
merci